[Musique]
les rues où c'était
[Musique] [
Musique] [Musique] [Musique
]
la basse
[Musique]
s'il te plaît, dis-nous pourquoi
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Je vais te montrer
[Musique] il y a
un endroit où être avec toi, regarde
autour de toi pour voir quoi faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
oui
[Musique]
maître blueskins, dis-nous pourquoi [
Musique] ce que
tu fais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] [
Applaudissements]
[Musique]
no pasa hijos de Cielo El Dorado Oh
Frances ela Franz DeVito a Falls détourne l'
univers de la France
ho - maple French manucure moi mais
les couches Eduardo pour encore plus étaient une nouvelle
page s'il te plaît
[Musique  ]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] [
Musique]
le soleil brille dans le ciel il y a
J'arrêterais de me battre avec
tout le monde dans la pièce,
c'est un beau nu
Hé,
vois comme le soleil brille dans la
ville dans la rue
où était autrefois bébé monsieur
[Musique  ]